i wanted to do something
community based
that was really the driving force find a
piece of the business you want to do
and see if you like it and if you want
to take it further start with baby steps
because anyone can begin that
exploration i assault you on the street
if you're eating mountain of my cookies
oh there she is
here i am we made it happen her first
instagram live everybody yay
this is this is helene
godin super successful entrepreneur runs
the company by the way bakery uh she's
got gluten-free dairy-free bakery here
are some of her new things the mo mix
so i love your story and and you know
we've got instagram here we're going to
save it put it on youtube as well
went from being a lawyer for 22 years
from a family of lawyers and assigned to
be an entrepreneur and just welcome
aboard my group is entrepreneurs and
want to be entrepreneurs and so i'm
super excited to dive into your story
i can't wait to share it
cool so one of the things that struck me
as i was looking into you know your
background so you spent 22 years as a
lawyer
you know that was your identity and then
you decide one day
i'm done with the law
you go talk to the general counsel and
say you know i'm done
and the response was
something like
i kind of expected this we've been
giving you twice the amount of work as a
normal person anyway
um
and we didn't think you'd make it this
far anyway so why don't we dial back
uh and your response is no i think i'm
done i got to go you know i got to do my
own thing first off
how did i i mean how did that what was
your reaction to that where it's like
you've been working me twice as hard as
everybody else you know what was the
first thing through your mind no let me
let me clarify he wasn't working me
twice as hard i was working me twice as
hard
okay because if you say jump i not only
say how high i take anti-gravity lessons
to do it even better
i love it okay so so then when they said
well let's talk about dialing it down
you know if if you are your own worst
enemy here that you're working you know
too long and and that's a you know new
york law is going to be a crazy number
of hour
roll
when so i guess like when do you know
when to quit like why why was it the
time now you have so much identity
wrapped into this your family's lawyers
22 years
it sounds like your general counsel is
willing to be flexible and
help you out but
how do you how did you decide no you
know what it's time to move on
well i i did it in in steps in my head
in that
two months before i had thought to
myself
okay this is this just isn't working and
you know i knew that dialing it down
wouldn't work because then i knew i
wouldn't be doing the job the best
possible job and i that's not my thing
um and so
i i actually i said i'm gonna give this
two months and then i said
no i'm gonna give this a month no i'm
just gonna give this a few weeks because
once you just once you decide to
to look at what you're doing you know
it's instead of just doing it
things open up i i
had always been afraid to examine it and
i was really happy and i hit a wall and
for a period of time wasn't ready to
admit how unhappy i was
and just kind of buried myself in
plowing through
and
i i don't i don't know
what came within me except just i had
sheer exhaustion
and said
no i gotta stop i gotta i gotta stop and
again i didn't wanna i it was stop
completely it wasn't do it half-assed
because that's just not me
i like it so we have a lot of
entrepreneurs watching and a lot of
people are at the beginning of their
journey as well especially on the replay
on youtube
what advice would you give them
if they're in a situation like you where
listen you've got a job you had a very
lucrative job you know they may not have
as lucrative
but but it's paying the bills and
they're you know they may not
they may not be treated like garbage at
their work they just
it's just kind of like good as the enemy
of a great
good is definitely the enemy of great
but you know i was the extreme because i
was working so many hours i didn't have
time to even formulate a plan
i i i knew that i i really had to take a
step back or i would just keep going and
never quit
but
most people aren't as crazy as you and
me and they're not working as many hours
and you can't say well i've got a
full-time job
and even i've got a full-time job and a
family so there's no more room because
you can find five or ten minutes
every day
to
to start crafting that plan to think
about ways no don't quit your job cold
turkey and open a store and then find
yourself
on a food line
but there are smaller ways to do things
and you've got to depending on the field
find that smaller way you know you want
you want to be a writer
right
you know you want to be a baker
bake and go to a farmer's market one
sunday just to see if you even really
like it i mean you should do that with
any career change
test the waters don't you don't have to
dive in deep in fact that could be a
mistake because then you'll find out
that what you left behind was actually
pretty good
which i've discussed with people so
i love the idea of testing and i know
you for a brief moment thought about
being a lit agent literary agent and you
know did one deal with your friend and
realized oh this is just another desk
job and i don't want this anymore
uh
it's interesting that you went from just
so corporate lawyer crazy hours but
being an entrepreneur is some crazy
hours too
i agree but it wasn't the hours it was
this isn't feeding my soul anymore
and i think most people will agree if
you're passionate about what you do
you can do it every waking moment
i love so let's dive into this because i
was so curious when i was looking at
your story so
you know you you leave your job you have
four days of retirement before you get
crazy restless and like i got to do
something
and
there were a lot of reasons why you know
with the law you want to do something
totally different not be a lit agent but
totally different
why of all things
a bakery
because a restaurant is too many nights
but why even at restaurants it's like
you're not cooking you're not i don't
cook i never do this day i don't care
i do not my kids used to know when they
were little it's like oh dad's not home
pizza
um
it was i wanted to do something
community based
that was really the driving force it
wasn't it wasn't the product or the
business itself it was
what could i do
where i could stay local and really
immerse myself in my community and give
back a bit you know i mean i spent many
years leaving before the sun came up and
coming back when the sun after the sun
came down
and i wanted to experience when i say
something different i really did want to
like see daylight in my town
and so that's how the exploration began
and i couldn't open a lingerie store but
i decided that i actually looked into it
and thought that
okay well that's it i didn't hear that
part of the story um
so so feeding the soul for you
was communities like i'm missing because
the work you're doing was important and
you had great clients and
yeah
i had great clients and i had great
colleagues but
um the craft of lawyering had changed i
mean i
i gave the example i
and again i really liked the clients i
worked with and i and i loved my
colleagues but like it was because i was
always exceeding expectations i remember
i had a conference call with one of my
clients and
the people on the other side of the
negotiation for whatever we were
licensing or doing
and he said oh but let's talk five
minutes before and i'll tell you about
the next project
then we did the call together
and
he
got on uh we the other side hung up and
he said so have you started that second
project yet
like how was i gonna do it i was with
you the entire time
so it just it was it was no longer
working for me
and do you have a sense of where that
missing community like why community is
so important to you
i think community is important to just
about everybody and and i actually
decide i i
maybe it's because my kids were getting
you know they were in high school and
were going to be leaving or just i just
really like people and was discovering
that in in the job i had
it was a bit too much of a microcosm
where i wasn't i wasn't growing as a
person
yeah
so the reason i asked is there's so many
people who who watch my content who they
want to do something else but in your
case like you left this lucrative job
without knowing where to go next it
wasn't like hey i've been having this
business plan for a year and i'm gonna
it's finally my time he's like i have no
idea what i want to do next and you
still had the courage to say i'm out and
i'm going to go figure it out
so it's just
a guidance or advice you might have for
somebody who
wants to try to figure out so like how
do you feed your soul for you it's
community for somebody else it might be
something else but how do you go through
that discovery process to figure out
what feeding the soul means you don't
have to you don't have to go cold turkey
you don't have to as i said dive in like
me you can do it in little pieces you
know if you're thinking of
opening a knitting store start by
teaching a friend how to make a sweater
you know find a piece of the business
you want to do
and see if you like it and if you want
to take it further you know like i took
the time and i spent a couple of days
with my friend it was a litter agent and
decided nope
not for me
so you said no to lit agent you said no
to lingerie store which i haven't heard
before which is which is interesting um
and presumably a whole bunch of other
ideas like why not a yoga studio or a
dance school or something oh because i
have no sense of rhythm i'm a terrible
dancer but you can't bake either but i
can't thank you but you can learn to
bake i feel like dancing you can do it
or you can't
no but here's the thing
is that it might not have worked i may
have hated baking yeah right it's not
like i quit being a lawyer started
baking decided oh this really sucks but
i'll do it anyway for the next 22 years
i happen to have stumbled upon the thing
pretty quickly
that i really liked but i didn't open a
store the next day
this was you know it was an accelerated
timeline but it was still a year of
first literally teaching myself how to
bake and seeing if i liked it and more
important seeing if i liked running a
business because i'm not a baker i still
do i don't i've never done the baking
for by the way
i've run the business what is that like
what you know i have to look at
ingredient costs and spreadsheets and i
have to come up with
menus and plans and i have to think
about seasonality
and that you know
i had the luxury of not being employed
at the time
but i still had to do the homework you
always have to do the homework
so was it just that
it was fun because i you know i read
you're
you're going on little tours and it's
stopping on every little bakery along
the way and taking notes of decor and
ingredients and what they're using and
how it tastes and all of these things
was it just that that was for some
reason fun for you where
lingerie store and something else wasn't
i no i looked at i thought what does the
community need and what will i find
interesting and i liked the idea
the lingerie store you also bring home a
bit of sweetness but a different
as i did my exploration it was what can
i do i love community what can i do to
enhance community for other people
right and as i i was thinking it was
you know what if i i don't just want to
open a regular bakery i want to open a
bakery for people who have special needs
special concerns
because number one it's a purple cow to
quote a famous author and
people will travel for it but number two
it will bring more people to the table
there was something about that that
resonated with me and it was really
bringing them to the table literally
like you have a gluten allergy of a
dairy allergy your kosher it was for me
able to say
you don't have to have the fruit plate
i'm very anti-fruit plate
i
i wanted to make sure like that what i
did
was a way of sort of giving back that i
would get to be within my community but
i would also create a community for
other people
there i love it
one now fast forward to today you've got
four locations i believe in and around
new york connecticut uh you got into
places like whole foods which is a crazy
story and amazing um and now launching
the moments the moments
and what i love about this is well one
you get to spread it almost feels like
you get to spread
the community
across america now so it's not just
coming into the bakery because there's a
story you know with this where it's you
and your 11 year old son
whose name is mo and you guys have been
making these things forever
um
what's what's the what's the goal and
like why now with
so you momex one of my secrets is that
my business has grown always organically
that it was i started with a little
store i saw how it went it was doing
okay so i opened a second store and then
i thought let me try wholesale and let
me see if i can make that happen
you know then it was
um
well you know now i'm into whole foods
what can i do to be in more whole foods
and we're baking out of a little
storefront but maybe we need a real
serious kitchen and the next thing on my
agenda was shipping
and
we big out of an 8 000 square foot
facility it's not small and yet we
barely have room for stamps
wow and in order to ship baked goods it
requires a ton of packaging
but momex is shelf stable
doesn't take up a lot of space you make
it you fill the bag you bring it you
send it out the door
and so
it was an opportunity
to explore shipping
while
developing more of a national reputation
and what's
what i love about you is there's so much
strategy that goes in everything
you know it's like okay so i wanted to
build the purple cow business that has
to be destination site it has to be
something that people will go to and not
just rely on local traffic and so here
it's like okay i want i want shipping i
want to explore this thing
where's the
what's the soul part of it like what
would it mean to you if
if you know christmas
10 million families had mo mix in their
stockings oh you should see me when i'm
walking down the street and someone else
is carrying a bag from one of my stores
i practically assault them like i am so
excited that they bought a cookie like i
it doesn't have to be a giant shopping
bag if it's a cookie i'm so excited and
like when i say thanksgiving is needless
to say our biggest holiday
am i
from the very first year in the we'll
we're going on our 10th thanksgiving
i when i sit down i am thankful for all
the people
who are sitting down at their table
sharing my baked goods that just makes
me so happy
how do you how do you scale
the community vibe
across america through through packaged
goods or is that even the goal with what
you're trying to do
you know i
i love
i love sharing
a part of me i mean i i
i won't get to meet every person i don't
need every customer now
but you know through telling my story to
people like you and
um
you know responding to instagram and
other things and i you gave great advice
to adam
earlier thank you
i'm at the dms but you know it's enough
to share and be as accessible as
possible right i can't cut myself into a
million pieces but to the extent that i
i can be a presence
i do it i assault you on the street if
you're eating mountain on my cookie
well you know it
so when i first got the package like oh
this looks cool it just looks like you
know everything else but then when you
read the thing on the back
talking about you and your son and you
know 40 batches of these and he's 11
years old it's kind of like you cut
yourself into a million pieces and
you're giving a little bit of helene you
know to america which i really enjoy
i'm gonna link it up so on on youtube
guys link will be in the description of
how to go and get your uh
bags of mo mix i have here what i've got
coconut almond
i've got
chocolate hazelnut
and then
this one i'm super excited by pecan chai
but you what what which one do you like
or which one does mo like the most
that's the question mo likes the
chocolate the best and
if you ask me that's like saying which
sun do you like better mo or alex so i
love them all or i wouldn't sell them
i love it cool uh so we're gonna link
all that up guys in the description
below any last message that you've got
to lean for an entrepreneur who
wants in this time to say finally i'm
i'm sick of the life that i've been
living i want to go off and do my thing
i see in this woman such an amazing
story that i look up to and want to be
like what part and advice would you give
them
like i've been saying
you may find that you really like what
you're doing or you may find that what
you were thinking of doing isn't what
you want to do so baby steps start with
baby steps because anyone can begin that
exploration
and you may surprise yourself
i love it helene go to the house the
company is by the way bakery the product
is mo mix we'll link it up and she's
done her first instagram live ever
thank you for showing up and uh super
excited to see this thing take off all
right take care bye-bye much love if you
want to see the one-on-one i did with
helene's husband seth godin check it out
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe and i'll see
you there skill this is really good news
is learnable when i started in the book
business i had bad taste
and editors didn't like what i thought
they would like